hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now we've got a new day ahead of us
Xavier slept like little angel babies
throughout the night and once we get
this underway will have farming
available but I did realize a problem I
didn't exactly build out a proper map
for me to go through I mean good job max
we're collecting wanted it have gone for
you I don't know why you're grimy but
you just keep doing what you're doing so
I'm gonna I'm gonna have a little
adventure because I'm gonna see what the
hell puffed is all about because puffs
may kill us all is there a way to save
could I save safe yes okay save save as
save as I don't know new safe do that
one ah we don't die that one save that
one our kickin alright so now I'm going
to do something that's probably risky
and we're going to dig through and say
hi to puff here extremely buoyant non
aggressive species rids itself of excess
pathogens by excreting lumps of slime
with each breath oh that's not that's
not what I want I don't think we want
slime slime is actually the opposite of
what we want so we're are I don't think
that's good
another surger Gus did you just give up
on digging your [ __ ] okay so max is
going to continue with his research he
definitely needs to do that we got to
get to the point where we can get the
farming Texas we can make the planter
box a compost and the algae terrarium
hey alright then so recycles carbon
carbon dioxide a small amount of oxygen
breaks down contaminated dirt into
fertilizer
so the poop farm that is my poop farm
will be able to have compost by it
that's good that's good
okay maybe maybe I shouldn't have had
that in the living quarters so this is
like the living quarters this over here
is a science quarter tech quarter or
whatever you want to call it I just go
for it
hurry up at least stretches down that's
nice cool you're doing great
next duplicating a long time don't need
to worry about more people right so
you're there you're doing that thing
making power you're good you're digging
can you dig more please
geez I'm gonna prioritize this dig
alright okay
yeah we go good we need to say say hi to
pop we could attack it that's true we
could do that I don't know if I want to
attack it
Oh Gus and Josie I don't you have to
attack past most is probably our friend
that's kind of poison all gasp maybe a
little bit hopefully all right so hi pop
I've gone oh that's a standoff uh I want
to attack it right away but it's a lot
of slime in there oh boy
go say hi to puffed is it destiny is it
destiny
oh they're about to meet first contact
okay then never mind
I already level four selected object
yeah all right then Oh going for it
what was he going for what are you going
for what's he going for that thing
alright then kill it oh boy oh my god
what is that what kind of gun is that oh
boy yeah oh I feel bad no oh god what am
i doing oh no man oh poor Punk
I just don't wanted to make poison gas
everywhere oh no don't go in there let's
contaminate it
oh boy oh oh it's so sad alright let's
at least dig out all the slime you don't
need that here Oh
[Music]
all right so what we did do even though
the slime is there can we sweep that up
we get that we get that out of there
please I don't know where we're gonna
put it I guess we have no place to put
it okay
but anyway gold amalgam holy [ __ ] hell
yeah gold amalgam okay I can dig that I
can literally dig that Oh killing creeps
hell yeah
okay so I think the only reason we're
losing oxygen is because wait why's this
we out of dirt we run out of dirt you
got to be joking we ran out of dirt okay
fine then we ran out of dirt oh no we
got it oh no we did the thing Oh fine
dining we don't need that we need liquid
piping to be able to get away from the
contaminated water and the chlorine gas
would be very nice okay so let's do
let's do liquid piping first and that'll
be the next test that we do and then we
will do continuous research yeah there
we go okay so that's going to keep going
that good so but now we've got new stuff
because we can make the algae terrarium
which is available we can just put
anywhere right we can put it over here I
guess Oh must be built on ground must be
built on ground I mean it's kind of on
ground I want to see what happens if we
put them over there and then maybe
they're gonna be able to produce a
little bit of oxygen yeah see what
happens buddy you got it I think all
right so that's going to do that then
refinement compost put it right by the
the [ __ ] here gonna stink like hell
over there but at least is going to be a
thing and then we're gonna we need to
make the planter box yeah so if we make
the planter box we can put them right
here yeah yeah okay I mean that's gonna
be good those don't require power so
they're good on their own and then we're
just gonna build what we need need more
power there need to build a planter box
got the algae things going on there yeah
there's going to be good because then
those are going to be able to emit
oxygen and consume carbon dioxide
because right now we don't have anything
consuming carbon dioxide so we probably
would have suffocated in the end anyway
yeah carbon dioxide it's there it exists
it is oh that's not good the slime is
bad oh [ __ ]
goddamnit ah the slime is bad is
producing a lot of oxygen oh god I
should have I should have done something
about that we need to we need to
definitely get another research station
up homeboy we need to do that that is
definitely a thing that we need to do oh
boy we're about to die we're all about
to die oh god I've done something
terrible I shouldn't have killed that
thing I couldn't kill the puffs it's
coming back to haunt me so we need
another power generator and we need
another battery we need to hook these up
bada-bing bada-boom Bo
kai bing bada boom Bo okay all right so
you guys are sleeping okay that's fine
that's totally fine the contaminated gas
is just over there and definitely just
not going to poison us all eventually
that's definitely not a thing that's
happening oh boy all right then
insufficient resources algae well where
do we get the algae I mean these things
have algae don't they police these
things are acting as a barrier to fight
back this contaminated oxygen but I got
a bad feeling that's going to be coming
for us very soon exceed selected Neal we
got mealworms so let's do the meal worm
all right
boink okay mealworms that'll be good
look at the composter here that's going
to be good building that up we're going
to have this to continuous research
continuously that's good so we'll have
to research stations to be able to do
that that's powering a lot of batteries
all right
good good good I think [ __ ] we just need
to get this this is are we doing gas
pumping are we doing liquid pumping
let's do gas pumping because we got a
problem contaminated gas a little sorry
Lenny you got to do it I apologize Lenny
Lenny I know you're stressed but I'm
sorry got to be done wow that's cool
Oh Lenny I'm sorry about that plenty I
don't need to do that we're running on
Gattaca those things growing we're
definitely not producing enough oxygen
whoo this is a little bit stressful guys
I'm sorry I'm not a very competent guy
yeah but we're starting to get carbon
dioxide in here so we are consuming too
much we do need more algae boxes but we
just don't have the algae for it it's
very toxic
that's just increasing from the slime
how do we get rid of the slime
I have no idea how to get rid of
something [ __ ] are we doing on research
gas piping doing good doing good okay
doing very good almost with that and
then maybe I think the gas piping will
be able to gas pump gas vent an out
point for gas pipes okay so gas pumping
the gas vent but I don't know where to
put the vent because we didn't put
anything and I have no idea how to build
dirt there Jesus ladder Oh
oh that's nice I didn't even know that
oh okay
can we put can we built this here and
puts lime in there can we can we do that
could we build this and put slime here
we do that click put this priority nine
please put with the Frick - that's not
what I was doing
priority nine please okay then
oh god damn it's time for sleep really
you guys got sleep when poisonous gas is
creeping up on your asses great okay
that's good you guys do your thing and
I'll just be a douchebag
oh boy gas permeable tile used as a wall
in floor tile to build room blocks the
flow of liquid without extracting gas
okay that's interesting power regulation
bigger battery into your decor best
table sculpting book okay so things are
just a little bit more stressful than
they have been but I think we'll be okay
I think it's gonna be all right
well that's horrifying but I think
that's gonna be okay maybe I shouldn't
have put that so close to all the living
areas but I don't think they're gonna
complain stress is only a little bit
high it's all any twenties fault the
stress bug I didn't get over it Lenny
all right so let me look into the gas
bridge okay gas pump dropping gas and
unser gas pipe gas pipe gas pipe bridge
shoot gas then how the heck how the heck
II would I build that oh boy I don't
know how to do that unless oh I know
what this is this is meant so maybe
maybe there's some sort of purifier
there's got to be some sort of purifier
because we're getting a lot of
contaminated oxygen here and that's
going to be very bad maybe there's like
a purifier that you can run this through
and then it would be able to output good
[ __ ] job to help they'll output good
[ __ ] okay that's we're we're in we're in
bad shape here I don't know what this is
but we're gonna put this here because I
got nothing better to do with my time so
we're just going to build this I don't
know where we're all going to die soon
very soon because the gas I the freaking
slime how do you get rid of the goddamn
flan can i put slime in here can I put
slime in here please tell me there's a
way to put slime in here organic what is
this is it organic slime organic put
organics in here but all organics in the
storage container and hopefully that'll
be good can we please oh god please tell
me that's possible climb-climb-climb Sam
are you going for the fun yes okay put
the slime
way she's um okay put the yes okay
storage compactor is gonna its emitting
oh [ __ ] oh god it's storing anyway oh no
oh no oh no well that's not good oh no
oh no guide them I'm sorry I don't know
what to do
I have no idea what to do probably
alright okay ah ah oh alright
advanced filtration ah there we go
advanced filtration okay ah I've done
bad guys I've done bad I've done wrong
by my people and I'm afraid that they
might die because I did not get the
advanced filtration that I needed which
is way way way down the road I unlocked
a horrible thing that I was not ready to
encounter and I'm afraid that everyone
might die here that doesn't mean that I
will give up I'll keep trying something
they're not gonna die but I'm gonna keep
trying I guess maybe I could try to wall
off maybe I maybe I could try to wall it
off what if I wall it off what if I wall
it off what if I wall it off god we got
a new citizen now now really oh boy
if wall it off please wallet come on
priority [ __ ] 9 where's that hi yeah
that's hi
[Music]
okay all right choose duplicate I guess
someone's gonna be in this [ __ ] all
right whatever
all right Jasper you're in here or no
you bet you bet you're in here okay all
right
can we get priority nine on this [ __ ]
cancel that one because we don't need it
food shortage I know I'm aware where the
Frick er my mealworms
what big up harvest it's not even close
to there oh boy
bad okay we walled it off so that means
that we'll just have to deal with what
we got and what we got so we're in a bad
spot but that doesn't mean that
everything is bad that means it's just
everything bad so at least we got your
vet here trying to help us out to that
that's good I guess
advanced filtration that'd be nice oh
that's the blue okay all right then well
we're we're gonna persevere we don't
have a bed for you bad sorry but oh so
anyway that's where I'm gonna end this
in mid crisis and we may come back to
this or they might all be dead I don't
know which one is more true at this one
so thank you everybody so much for
watching they are sleeping in poisonous
gas but that's okay I think the things
everybody so much for watching let me
know how I'm doing in the comment below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]